من بعد معاناه طويله عاشها العالم مع وباء
كورونا مجددا عاد الحديث بحذر هذه المره
مع مرض فيروس ماربور تحذيرات وتوصيات
اطلقتها عده دول منها السعوديه وعمان
بتجنب السفر الى تنزانيا وغينيا
الاستوائيه بعد رصد تفش للمرض هناك
المعروف بالمرض الفتاك يقتل نحو 90% من
المصابين به
هذه النسبه الكبيره والتي تؤكد على خطوره
الفيروس وفق تقارير منظمه الصحه دفعت بطرح
الكثير من الاسئله عن طبيعه الفيروس ومدى
قوته لكن السؤال الاكثر بحثا كان هل من
المتوقع ان يصبح فيروس مارفور كووباء
كورونا الفيروس تم التعرف عليه للمره
الاولى عام
يمكن ان ينتقل عبر احد انواع خفافيش فاكهه
او يمكن ان ينتقل بين الافراد عبر سوائل
الجسم
تتراوح فتره حصانه الفيروس من يومين الى
21 يوما
وتبدا اعراض المرض بحمى شديده وصداع حاد
ووعكه شديده لتزداد الاعراض باسهال والام
في البطن وتقيؤ ومن بعد ثمانيه ايام قد
يتسبب الفيروس في موت المصاب بسبب النزيف
الحاد
تقارير الطبيه اكدت انه لا توجد لقاحات او
علاجات معتمده لعلاج هذا الفيروس لكن هناك
اطباء وجدوا ان الرعايه الداعمه بالسوائل
الفمويه او الوالديه قد تساعد في شفاء
المصابين وانقاذهم من الموت